Gerardo Zavala es un artesano conocido
como El rey del trompo y se fuerza por
crear juguetes con su torno de madera
para preservar las tradiciones y
culturas sobre todo en tiempos donde los
dispositivos electrónicos son los
favoritos de los niños es el rescate de
los juegos tradicionales y que los niños
vuelvan a ser
actores y no meros espectadores porque
esta clase de juegos del desarrolla
destrezas que luego le servirán también
bastante en el futuro según la profesión
que escojan
Marta Pacheco también artesana de
juguetes se hace Llamar la hojalatera de
la ronda desde los 7 años comenzó con su
padre al oficio
elabora el tradicional nacional con
el que los niños juegan a ser autoridad
de tránsito también ollas cocinas y
tambores se cuentan entre sus creaciones
para ella la infancia Se está perdiendo
porque los niños ya no quieren los
juegos tradicionales y nos sentamos y
compartimos el té compartamos nuevamente
hagamos el arroz hagamos la sopita y
vamos a compartir con nuestros hijos y
vamos a comer y con nuestros niños
enseñarles nuevamente el valor del
tambor canciones muy fáciles A
diferencia de la artesanía Samuel
cartaya canta para fomentar vínculos
entre padres e hijos es un músico
terapeuta sus composiciones van
dirigidas a romper el aislamiento que
provocan los dispositivos electrónicos
hemos desviado un poco hacia el lado de
los objetos de regalar el juguete y no
construir el juego es muy importante
entender que lo que realmente hace que
Nuestros peques crezcan sanos y se
desarrollen de manera ideal no es que
estén rodeados de juguetes sino que
estén rodeados de juego juegos unos que
tres artesanos
las relaciones sociales actitudes y el
carácter de los niños frente a la
sociedad